foreign
conditions for the displays are getting
desperate with just two hours to Sunset
food is served in this camp that
officials say now accommodates hundreds
of people
this rule is not enough for about 3 000
people that is here
3 000 people depend on this this road
and we bought it from charity charity
was
she says they haven't received any
relief supplies from government
this is flights have ravaged at least 27
of Nigeria's 36 States destroying lives
crops and homes in regions like anambra
efficiency I tell us that hundreds of
thousands of people in several
communities are still Out Of Reach
nothing has been heard from some of them
in nearly a week and the passengers of a
boat that capsized a week ago killing
about 90 people who are fleeing their
submerged communities in search of help
emergency agencies had warned of
destructive floods this year but the
level of government preparedness was
poor so too was people's response to
evacuation warnings that has left
victims like engaged wondering what the
future holds
[Music]
go back to houses left standing my
animals crops everything is gone
Edinburgh is one of the worst affected
States officials say the danger signs
have been there yet the federal
government has failed to act
Cameroon warns about this and so we know
that every two three years this happens
Cameroon will open up the dam
and then he comes here and wipes off
everything I mean it gonna get to a
point where the water will come and
develop the entire country
Nigerian officials say humanitarian
supplies have been distributed
Nationwide but that is little comfort
for hundreds of thousands who are yet to
receive any help from government at any
level how many degrees Al Jazeera or
twitcha